[Music]
it's no secret that the draconian
lockdowns have wreaked havoc on small
businesses all around the country
one small business lancaster california
took a double hit on super bowl sunday
of all days
the la county health inspector entered
what's called the
bravery brewery company after telling
employee that they had to shut down for
covert 19 violations
well then after that moment that
inspector was caught on camera
you can see right there appearing to be
well carefree cavalier maybe even
dancing that's right moments later after
telling the brewery to close your doors
uh not a care in the world seen on
surveillance video clapping her hands
maybe dancing certainly not upset in any
way
we reached out to the la county health
inspector her supervisor
and the press office asking for comment
they won't respond
joining us now one of the co-owners of
the bravery brewery company is bart
avery
you know i'm watching this and i'm you
know first
this is important to get out of the way
first by the way thank you for being
with us i'm sorry what happened to you
and your business
you weren't serving people inside you
were you were
doing draft beers to go and people were
coming in and taking it out
correct correct we were we we have no
tvs at bravery brewing company so
every super bowl we don't bother to try
to be open during the game so
we advertised that up front that we were
just going to be beer to go which is
basically
cans bottles crawlers growlers so our
first two customers came in
and we don't need to have a food truck
and then this inspector showed up and
all this stuff happened okay so now
you actually quoted in the article
saying that
these draconian shutdowns have decimated
your business financially
and emotionally for people that well
fairly cavalier
explain what explain exactly what that
means
well i mean financially it's it's a huge
hit
we haven't made a dime we've lost so
much money over the last nine or ten
months
emotionally my my wife and i are both
well into our 60s
we're working seven days a week 10 12
hours a day
because at times we've had to lay off
all of our employees we're doing
whatever it takes
to to make this work and sean i almost
didn't make it on camera here because
literally minutes ago it's windy up here
my tents where all
all of my poor customers are forced to
sit right now because of the
county mandates we're blowing down and
luckily i had some customers and some
friends there that were able to help put
these tents
kind of back together with duct tape but
i mean this
is what we're facing it's it's just
terrible and it's not just us it's so
many small businesses
especially the folks out here in los
angeles county
when you look at your state and now you
have this recall of gavin newsom out
there you look at what happened in new
york governor cuomo you
look at michigan you look at new jersey
pennsylvania
then you compare it to ron desantis down
in florida
ron desantis pretty much stayed open as
much as he could
and and kept the most vulnerable
population
safe doing a much better job with
vaccine distribution
and i i got to be wondering if
you're thinking let me get the hell out
of here go to texas or florida
yeah you know we've been doing this
all wrong shallots you take away church
libraries bars
restaurants people are still going to
socialize we're social animals
so now you're going to go from a safe
environment like
like mr de santo has in florida where
people are wearing masks people are
spaced
to a situation where people out here
that can't do what they're doing in
florida
are going to people's houses smoking
cigars
10 people in a garage drinking beer and
wine very unsafe
what's going on in florida should be
going on here right now the stuff
they've been doing isn't working
we need to allow people to be able to go
back inside
we need to be able to allow people to
have a beer without having to buy a meal
it's it's it's killing us it's killing
us small business people
and i'm hoping that that this maybe is
the is the changing point where people
see what happened on this and maybe
things will change and get better for us
i hope so i i hope so too by place looks
awesome i look like a cool place i'd
like to hang out
be very blunt with you um i wish you and
you're you're
you're very welcome i want i'm gonna
come next time i'm there if i can get
there i'd love to
i'd love to be out there but don't laugh
at me i put ice in my beer that's awful
right that's like that's
unforgivable
my very best sir okay